only on 8 tonight surveillance video
that seems to show the moments just
before
a deadly crash involving a unlv
basketball recruit
the i-team's david charns joining us now
from the newsroom with the details on
that david
and denise recruits ann collins facing
charges of dui resulting in death and
reckless driving resulting in death
metro telling us collins crashed a dodge
challenger into another car at the
intersection there on your screen this
is at fort apache in furnace
gulch now take a look at this
surveillance video sent to us
by a viewer taken at fort apache in
gomer right before the crash
gomer just two streets down from furnace
gulch it shows a gray dodge
challenger speeding down the road and if
you follow the car
up to the next intersection it's where
furnace gulch is you can see the
beginning of a collision
of a white car we'll post the video
again on our website for you to take a
closer look there
also worth noting tonight is collins
past violations when it comes to driving
a search of traffic case records showing
he was stopped for speeding
exceeding the posted limit by 21 miles
per hour or greater in september 2018.
he was then stopped again in november
2018 for the same violation and then in
july
of 2020 he was stopped for driving the
wrong way
on a one-way live in the newsroom
tonight i'm david charns 8 news now